okay so in this quick video we're going
to go over the basic steps of the water
cycle how water moves through the
atmosphere so let's go ahead and get
started
well titled here I have the hydrologic
cycle which is just a fancy way of
saying the water cycle now when I look
at the water cycle or the hydrologic
cycle its definition is simply the
movement of water through the atmosphere
so when we look at a picture of the
earth here we can see that the vast
majority of the surface of the earth is
covered by water about seventy five
percent the problem is the majority of
the water that is on the surface of the
earth is undrinkable the picture on the
left is just a picture of salt implying
salt water the picture on the right
shows some frozen glaciers and icebergs
and so most of the water is undrinkable
because it's either too salty or frozen
so when we when we talk about you know
water conservation keep in mind that
there's you know about seven billion
people on earth drinking from a very
small percentage of fresh drinking water
well let's go ahead and look at the
stages of the water cycle
so when we look at the stages of the
water cycle water rises into the
atmosphere in one of two ways
probably the moat the most obvious one
is through evaporation and then the
animation I have h2o standing for water
water rising out of this pond into the
atmosphere and that's simply called
evaporation heat from the Sun causes
liquid water liquid water in the pond to
turn into a gas form so water goes
through a change of state from a liquid
to a gas a second way that water rises
into the atmosphere is to what's called
transpiration transpiration is where
plants lose water through their leaves
let's actually look at that in a little
more detail
so one thing I want you to know when we
focus on transpiration in a little more
detail is that plants have these little
pores on the backside of their leaves
well here's a picture of a plant leaf
and let's go ahead and zoom on in with a
microscope so we can get a closer look
at what's called their stomata and
here's one single stomata here or stowe
mate for singular and what we see in the
animation is water evaporating from from
this stomata here and the stomata have
the ability to open and close and plants
will have hundreds of these per leaf and
these stomata can open and close and
this is how they exchange gas so you
know that plants need carbon dioxide in
order to do photosynthesis so when the
stomata are open they can take in carbon
dioxide and I think you know that plants
also give off oxygen when they do
photosynthesis and so when the stomata
are open oxygen can escape from the leaf
well when the stomata are open it's not
just oxygen that escapes but also water
vapour and so this is transpiration in a
little more detail it's where plants
lose water they lose water through
evaporation because these stomata are
opening and closing throughout the life
of the plant
so here we have our animation showing
evaporation and transpiration well all
this water as it rises into the air
collects in the atmosphere and so over
time water begins to build up and
collect again this is water vapor gas
water gas builds up and collects in the
atmosphere what happens next now that
there's a bunch of water vapor
collecting in the atmosphere this leads
to a process called condensation this is
where the water is going to turn from a
gas back into liquid and the cause of
this is cool temperatures let's take a
break from the water cycle for a moment
and just focus on an everyday occurrence
that you probably have seen 100 times
here's a bottle a soda bottle on a nice
hot sunny day let's say you're drinking
some soda outside and you put the bottle
down for a few minutes then you come
back a few minutes later you might
notice that little droplets of water
have accumulated on the outside of the
water bottle where did the water come
from did the bottle leak no the reason
there's little droplets of water is
because that water bottle that soda
bottle is really cold you just took it
out of the refrigerator and so the
moisture that's in the air came into
contact moose Chur in the air came into
contact with that cold bottle and it
condensed forming little liquid droplets
well if we relate this to the water
cycle
by relating this to the water cycle that
is how we see clouds form clouds are the
other results of condensation water
vapor will condense and form clouds and
when the liquid water of clouds gets
heavy enough of course it will rain and
so when we look at the next stage of the
water cycle we have precipitation and in
the animation we have water h2o falling
out of the cloud well when we look at
precipitation there's different types of
precipitation most obvious being this
picture here of rain here's another
picture of precipitation snow and here's
a form of precipitation called sleet and
if you're not familiar with sleet it's
kind of like a frozen rain sleet is
actually very slippery and hard to drive
on because it's also you might hear the
phrase black ice because when water
freezes on a on a road you can't even
really see it and so the road might look
clear but it's really a real thin layer
of ice on the road very slippery hard to
drive on be careful and then a fourth
kind of hit of precipitation called hail
little small balls of ice that fall from
clouds and here we see a person holding
some hail the in their hand now the ones
in this picture here are are not too
common the two the usual size of hail is
smaller than peas so the hail balls are
usually not as large as the picture here
but when they are they can cause some
damage you look at this picture right
here
you can see the back window of this
automobile broken because of hail
damaged
so now that waters on the ground so it's
been raining or sleet or some kind of
precipitation now that water's on the
ground what happens next well water is
going to do one of two things
notice in the animation water is simply
running downhill and that's simply
called runoff so when water hits the
ground it's going to roll downhill into
a river into a lake into an ocean water
is going to roll downhill into its
lowest point which eventually is
probably going to be one of the oceans
well as water is running downhill it
also might soak into the ground and
that's what the word infiltration means
when water hits the ground it can soak
into the soil and this will create
what's called groundwater so in our
animation we have some h2o s
accumulating under the ground and this
is where a lot of the of the world gets
their drinking water from is from
groundwater let's look at that really
quickly in a little more detail
when we look at this picture here we can
see kind of a cutaway of the surface of
the earth and then underneath the
surface we see the flow of groundwater
well what we often do is we'll drill
wells down into the groundwater supply
and that will supply drinking water and
cleaning water and bathing water
well you might wonder well if we drill
down in mik wells won't we run out of
groundwater well the reason why we don't
run out of groundwater is because of
infiltration when water soaks into the
ground infiltration will replenish or
recharge the groundwater supply so let's
come back to our animation here let's
just kind of show all the steps at once
so here we have evaporation water
evaporating from this pond and now I've
added transpiration water evaporating
from the leaves of the tree and so as
the water goes up eventually it's going
to form clouds and clouds are the
results of condensation when the gas of
when the water gas turns back into a
liquid gas I said that wrong when water
gas turns back into a liquid that's
called condensation and eventually that
liquid gets heavy enough where it falls
as precipitation whether it's snow rain
sleet or hail and once water is on the
ground let's say it's rain once it rains
water is going to do one of two things
once it's on the ground it's either
going to run off downhill or it's going
to soak into the soil but if you look in
the animation here we have a cycle a
continuous around the clock cycle here
known as the hydrologic cycle or the
water cycle so I'm going to just let
this play for a few moments before we
conclude with a little practice quiz
you
okay so here we have a practice quiz go
ahead and pause the video and if you're
in my class try to answer these
questions on a separate sheet of paper
and bring them to me I'd love to check
them for accuracy so go ahead and pause
the video and try to answer these good
luck